اذا
مراسل العربيه يفيد بان الجيش الاسرائيلي
اسقط مسيره انطلقت من جنوب لبنان وهذه هي
صوره هذه المسيره التي اسقطها الجيش
الاسرائيلي
ومراسل العربيه افاد بان هذه المسيره كما
ذكر الجيش الاسرائيلي انطلقت من جنوب
لبنان بالطبع بالامس شهدت المنطقه
الحدوديه توترا لافتا بعد اطلاق
زخات من صواريخ الكاتيوشا والجراد من
مناطق في جنوب لبنان قدرت باكثر من 30
صاروخا على المستوطنات الشماليه في
اسرائيل ما استدعى ردا اسرائيليا
بغاره جويه بعد
منتصف الليل على بعض البساتين الزراعيه
التي انطلقت منها هذه
الصواريخ بدون الافاده عن وقوع
ضحايا اذا هذه صوره للمسيره
التي اسقطها الجيش الاسرائيلي لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات